hey we have a challenge
from couple people
okay random challenge between these two
playing
johan tan
okay
final game
i want to play a new opening
okay i'm going to play uh a line
that i encountered in iceland
is c6
actually let's play let's let's play a
little bit uh
freakishly
g5
oh no my pawn
okay so this is a poison pawn because
queen a5 check
i feel like i've played this like maybe
once or twice
i usually don't play the combination of
knight six and c6
anyway
i hope people are enlightened
this is a
a four move trap against london
to win the bishop
okay i'm getting a little bit greedy
here
uh white does have rook g1 ruchi one
queen here rook g3
queen will survive
thank you mammon
now it's a matter of using the extra
piece
yeah probably 97 castle and queenside
the general plan
when white has a structure and i have a
pawn on d6
is to go for e5 e4
hey eric could you play a cambridge
springs oh
i could try cambridge springs requires
white to play
like kind of mainline queen's gambit
so
i can't really play cambridge springs
against london
but
i'd be open to trying
to play e5 here
yeah some pressure against g4
but also pressure against f3 i play
queen's gambit and am challenging you
ooh
[Music]
uh make sure you challenge me with the
white pieces
and then maybe i'll accept your
challenge
okay using the diags
so both knights are pinned
this is an absolute pin
and this is a relative pin
so if you're playing your mom or dad or
brother or sister that's a relative pin
if you're playing chess after the chess
club closes it's sub-zero that's an
absolute pin you guys got that the
difference being this knight can't
legally move this knight could move but
it's bad
uh so now i can
[Music]
i can take this knight
knight takes i win the queen if queen
takes i win the knight
did i check my own rusen score i checked
last night
there's a new feature on rosenscore
where you can see you can filter based
on
[Music]
how recent you want the games to be
so last night i checked my rusen score
for like the most recent six hours
and i had zero trophies
i don't think i'll be getting a trophy
this this game
unless i really want to try for one
but i'm up a night
wait
no i'm up a rook and a pawn
no mercy here
it might be hard to mate with pawn
i'll see what i can do
yeah special thanks to traveler
creator of rosenscorer link is in the
chat
okay i could win another pawn
[Music]
might as well there's f3 here
after which i think
like d5 looks nice
oh
i'll admit i didn't see that move coming
but uh
yeah it's still quite nice for me
now there might be some smother made
potential
or some smothered pork meat
okay let's unpin
if i took the knight i'd lose my knight
i kind of want to play
okay first with queen c2 i kind of want
to play this move
yeah i think my opponent's gonna flag
before checkmate happens
i'm not seeing a good way to force
smothermate so
might as well just meet
okay
so i'm curious how many people have
fallen for this trap on the chest
i have the master's database open
so no one's played g5 and masters
oh wait
yeah no one's played g5 in masters
database
a novelty on the chest i'd imagine there
is
there's gotta be at least a thousand
games
maybe that's like a thousand games and
let's say 400 people falling for the
trap
oh wow
7 700 games
and over 3 000 people falling for this
trap
yeah because it looks like a free pawn
like as white you really need to have
the port vision
and this is actually a common idea in
the cambridge springs as well
i'm not sure if i'll have time for
cambridge springs game but
cambridge springs is
there's different move orders but it's
this opening
um
essentially getting to this position
and then queen a5
and there's ideas of
targeting the king and the bishop
so i hope
people learned a thing or two